yeah I heard you broke up were you gonna
date now that you can date anyone I
don't know I think I'd like to be on my
own for a bit I mean obviously if
someone special comes along but I mean
really special like nothing I've even
remotely considered in the past we sure
want that shine of love shoot that
docking kind of luck yeah like penis in
the foreskin kind of love isn't warm
just like hey everybody [ __ ] off Morty I
need your help we need to go on a quick
adventure you said I could go to school
today
that was before I needed something more
tea there's a plasma shard in the Abbott
dongho cluster a princess has it if I
get it I'll be awesome we've been going
nonstop Rick it's not healthy you know
these are my teenage years I just found
out Jessica's single oh that's Wow
Morty Wow what an exciting life you lead
go in and out 20 minutes adventure
I did the burps for Rick this season
daddy Morty fighter John they're on our
tail
steady goddamn it to see John's
it's known as that looked like a
butthole hmm and then there's a vagina
then
like the Star Wars can't [ __ ] do this
anymore seriously [ __ ] um we almost
died
so you agree MUC yes that would this was
insane that was pure luck I was not in
control of that situation at all
ah look at this warning
look at my [ __ ] hand look at this [ __ ]
why do you keep doing this dog I don't
know Morty maybe I hate myself maybe I
think I deserve to die I don't I don't
know vacation
hey youtubers is Charlie new Rick and
Morty season 3 footage who basically
like a Star Wars Death Star trench run
parody done to look like this big
metaphor for sex so I'm going to break
down explain what the hell's going on
there is a new round of the giveaway and
because there's a hard cover of the
comic they just released that's
basically what it's for all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything so the reason this looks
kind of weird is because this aired
during a developer's meeting for Adult
Swim so that's why like I had to
whiteout part of that message there
ahead like there phone number on it so I
can't put that in the video but this is
just so completely insane and this is
all about morty being a complete horn
dog and going after Jessica who's not
going out with Brad anymore
I love the way that Jessica intros it to
like she totally calls out that she is
DTF and Rick just walks in and just like
shut up everybody I need Morty for an
adventure and they take off Rick has
always been kind of a [ __ ] block when it
comes to morning like he always tries to
horn in on Jessica and it goes sideways
like when he had the love potion and it
turned into Cronenberg world
but the way they cut this clip out of
the episode which looks like it's from
maybe like season 3 episode 6 just based
on the timecode up front but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's going
to air as the sixth episode so this will
appear somewhere in season three they go
off to find this crystal that Rick wants
and it turns in like like if you look at
the way that they do this art it's
basically a bunch of sperm chasing them
in this giant vagina that they're going
after so one of the funny things you can
consider it rolling you can consider it
hilarious you know whatever is that they
said that they added a lot of testicles
in the background like season 2 finale
look at all these these are all
testicles so if you listen to the
commentary track sometimes they'll joke
about that now they're like oh yeah we
asked for way more testicles in this
episode but now that you know this when
you re-watch episodes look for stuff
like this in the animation if you didn't
notice it before like oh yeah that kind
of does look like a giant vagina with a
bunch of sperm chasing them so really
just taken in that context this clip is
all about Morty being obsessed with sex
with Jessica then they fly off into a
space adventure which becomes a metaphor
for having sex the other best example of
this is the plum the sad plum bus
everybody has one today on how they do
it plum basis' everyone has a plum Basim
first they take the Dingle pop and they
smooth it out with a bunch of Schliemann
is then repurposed for later batches
they take the Dingle Bop and they push
it through the grumbo where the fleed
is rubbed against it it's important that
the fleet is rubbed because the fleed
has all of the fleep juice then ash
Lommy shows up and he rubs it and spits
on it they cut the fleep there's several
his ERDs in the way the blimps rub
against the tumbles and the ploobis and
grumbo are shaved away that leaves you
with a regular old plum bus I was
wondering how plum this has got me then
they get the Star Wars metal ceremony
from the end of episode 4 they even add
some Star Wars style music on top of
this and then proceeded to drop as many
f-bombs as possible for like the next 30
seconds of this clip
let me know what you guys think of this
Star Wars style Death Star vagina
parody video I love that there's a Star
Wars movie now about stealing the plans
for the Death Star that we all just saw
this past week in Rick and Morty just
posted this random clip that they've
been working on for the past year but
they've been working on this for a long
time so they didn't just think of this
in the last couple of weeks this
happened way earlier this year but they
basically turned the Death Star trench
run itself into a metaphor for
impregnating a woman just completely
amazing and ridiculous in the best
possible way I cannot wait for season 3
to get here so let me know what you guys
think of this and what is the funniest
thing that you found in the background
animation like something that they
didn't totally call out to like there
was the butt world that they teleported
to with all the gas there was the world
where everything was on a cob that's
usually the one that everybody quotes
everything is on a cob let's get the
hell out of here they're just so much of
this stuff in every single episode but I
am actually pretty surprised that they
went that far with this clip but this is
pretty not-safe-for-work so I'll be
interested to see how they change this
for the final edit because this is just
an animatic so they could change the
little bits of this cut some stuff out
or even add stuff in but Justin roiland
was actually talking about Rick and
Morty season 3 real soon he said it's
coming along he couldn't say exactly how
many episodes he'd seen final edits up
but he did say it was coming really soon
so that seems to confirm everyone's
belief that it's going to be sometime in
March but aside from the old favorites
like squanchy or like the really really
big side characters I'm expecting them
to introduce a whole bunch of new
characters like giant telepathic spiders
that's kind of what I'm expecting from
the storyline in this clip here like the
sperm people in the giant vagina but you
guys can let me know like which
characters do you want them to bring
back and I know there's the multiverse
theory so we have different versions of
every single character that could be
alive just like there are a ton of
Morty's just like the idea that c-137
Rick isn't on his first morty and also
let me know what kind of Rick and Morty
videos you guys want me to do in the
next couple weeks I will do a video
about the evil Morty in the idea that
Rick isn't on his first morty just based
on that episode c130
the council apologizes for its false
accusation and in the way of reparations
for our terrible mistake we would like
to compensate you with this voucher for
a free replacement more tea in the event
that your current more tea shut up guys
not a good time so lots more Rick and
Morty coming there'll be some new Star
Wars new DC and Marvel in the next
couple of days but next Rick and Morty
should be next week sometime I'll say
congratulations to the first giveaway
winner mark McCauley just please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
win one of the new Rick and Morty
hardback comic collections nice a bird
off channel icon too so whole bunch of
stuff coming tomorrow look out for that
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my Rick and Morty
Theory video and you can click here for
the latest flash trailer I just posted
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]